tous les baristas vous le diront
préparez un bon café c'est un art mais
pour l'astrophysicien Jonathan Garnier
chaque tasse contient aussi une forte
dose de science
Jonathan gagné est astrophysicien au
Planétarium de Montréal son parcours
universitaire l'amené dans différentes
villes d'Amérique du Nord pour passer à
travers ces longues heures d'études il a
bu beaucoup de café et il a développé
une appréciation pour la complexité des
arômes de ce breuvage
je suis revenu à Montréal ensuite à la
fin de mon poste doctorat en 2018 et là
tout d'un coup mon café goûtait vraiment
plus mauvais et je comprenais pas
pourquoi
le problème c'est que il y a beaucoup de
paramètres qui a fait que le goût c'est
très difficile de dire à ça c'est dû au
moulin ça c'est dû à l'eau mais aussi la
quantité de composés chimique qui a dans
le café qui donne son goût particulier
et ça change d'une variété de café à
l'autre il a donc mis à profit ses
connaissances en physique en chimie et
en informatique pour trouver comment
préparer le café idéal ces recherches
l'ont même mené à publier un livre sur
la physique du café filtre
c'est dans l'eau que Jonathan gagné à
trouver son premier élément de réponse
l'eau de l'aqueduc de Montréal est très
riche en bicarbonate de soude si on a
trop de bicarbonate ben les cafés font
goûter un peu plus le goût générique de
café et ça va empêcher de voir les
nuances de chaque pays et de chaque
variété
pour contourner ce problème le
scientifique a décidé de préparer ses
propres recettes d'eau je vais prendre
de l'eau distillée je vais ajouter
moi-même au compte-goutte les concentré
de minéraux donc ici j'ai dû chlorure de
calcium
ici j'ai dû chlorure de magnésium et ici
j'ai du bicarbonate de soude dans le
monde du café de spécialité on aime
mettre plus de magnésium parce que ça
fait ressortir un goût un peu différent
un peu plus complexe viens ensuite le
choix des grains que Jonathan gagné se
procure chez les torréfacteurs locaux
la cuisson des grains modifie leur
composition chimique et influencent le
goût du breuvage final
au niveau de la couleur des grains de la
différence de profil que ça va amener
ici c'est un Péruvien lavé c'est notre
version d'un rose expresso mais c'est
sûr que on va laisser un peu plus
longtemps dans le four le sortir une
température un peu plus haute elle est
développée les sucres
Colombie lavé c'est dès qu'on aura le
bac là ça paraissait le ça sent les
agrumes il y a vraiment de l'acidité un
côté floral aussi c'est pas mal ce type
de couleur là que j'aime beaucoup c'est
la couleur c'est vraiment éducatif de
comment longtemps ça a été torréfié
Bacter la vitesse que les réactions
chimiques se sont passées quand tu
torréfiais ça va changer c'est quoi
qu'il y a dedans au final de retour chez
lui Jonathan gagné si par ses grains en
doses individuels qu'il ne mou qu'au
moment de préparer son café
la percolation de l'eau dans le café a
beaucoup en commun avec l'écoulement
d'eau à travers les sédiments en
géologie
grâce à sa compréhension de ses
principes scientifiques le chercheur
peut déterminer la taille de mouture
appropriée je vais utiliser une mouture
qui est plus plutôt grossiale donc plus
gros pour éviter que l'eau s'écoule
autour des particules donc si c'est trop
difficile passer entre les petites
particules de café bien compressées mais
elle va passer au tour puis les composés
chimiques sont responsables pour
l'astringence c'est des très grosses
molécules qui ont tendance à
s'agglomérer qui sont pas bien dissolus
dans l'eau et quand que l'eau s'écoule
très bien à travers le café ils vont pas
se retrouver dans notre tasse pour
s'assurer que la taille de la mouture
est uniforme l'astrophysicien a
programmé un logiciel qui la mise à la
disposition des amateurs de café à
travers le monde donc ici j'ai moulu une
petite quantité de café que je peux
saupoudrer sur une surface blanche après
on peut prendre une photo et analyser
dans une application que j'ai faite pour
déterminer la distribution des
différentes tailles particules donc la
hauteur de la courbe rouge me dit
combien de particules de chaque taille
pour
guérir collation c'est bien effectué il
eut une fois un réfractomètre
cet appareil muni d'un prisme en sa
fille et d'une diode électroluminescente
mesure la réfraction de la lumière à
travers le liquide
ça permet de mesurer la concentration du
café dans le breuvage à la fin et en
connaissant le poids de café qu'on a mis
la quantité totale de café et sa
concentration on peut déterminer la
fraction qui a été extraite
santé
mais au-delà de ces mesures
scientifiques l'amateur de café se fit
surtout sur ses papilles
un goût de pêche donc dans la cité et
sur la fin j'ai je détecte un peu de
sucré mais c'est un peu comme du caramel
brûlé
je crois pas qu'il existe une méthode
parfaite juste parce que il y a des
préférences de goûts qui sont
différentes je pense qu'on s'approche
d'une méthode qui est optimisée pour le
style que je préfère moi
grâce aux travaux de Jonathan gagné
préparé un bon café mais plus seulement
un art mais aussi une science